well you know there's nothing much you
can do about the the weight of
expectations once you've finished making
the film you know and so the last few
months actually been really pleasurable
and you have to kind of seal yourself
off from the white noise of everybody
you know speculating about what the
movie might be or what might happen
afterwards and just get on with making
the film so and because I've been really
excited to show people it's actually
been it's been great I've really enjoyed
it
the tough part was shooting it which was
really it was really tough of eight
months of because you know there were
injuries and illnesses and so many
different countries to shooting and the
schedule kind of got longer and longer
and the release date got closer and
closer so that was that was tricky and
one of the very interesting plot lines
is about surveillance yeah and do you
feel like you're over monitored we're
over monitored in this country and in
the world personally I do yeah in the
world I couldn't comment I feel like
there's a great danger that we lose all
privacy yes and I think that you know
it's of course a very good argument that
the government sometimes an mi5 make
about the need for surveillance in terms
of you know the prevention of terrorism
however that doesn't mean that everyone
should be treated equally and everyone
should be equally guilty or treated as
if they are guilty before proven
innocent and so so I think it's
something that I've managed to get into
the film that I feel quite strongly but
the reality is now you know you you have
a there was a time wasn't there when
Bond was personally accepted that mi6
were the good guys you know and that
there was no question about that but now
the public is ambivalent about about
surveillance and about Secret Service
and about the you know security services
generally both national and
international and so I felt it necessary
that we we create we split the security
services in two in this movie one of the
sides of that debate is animated through
Andrew Scott's character see who's the
end of mi5 and believes in surveillance
and believes in drones and not putting
people on the ground and the other side
of that debate is
ray finds an M and of course bond who
believed in looking a man in the eyes
before you kill them and that's
something I feel very strongly and and
you know we felt it necessary to do that
because it's not just accepted that he's
the good guy anymore and one of the
reasons possibly that bond has continued
for so long is its ability to reinvent
itself and can you imagine a time when
there is a black bond a female bond can
I imagine of course you can imagine
anything do I
you know think about it personally no I
think in a way one of the things you
have to focus on when you're making a
Bond movie is you know I'm a filmmaker I
make one movie other people responsible
for the franchise and sometimes you can
get the two things confused my job is to
make this one story and this is my bond
and this is my absolute commitment you
know to the audience and to the people
are gonna go see the cinema go to the
cinema see the movie over the next few
months the rest of it is in the hands of
other people and I think that it can be
taken a little too seriously
and I also think that you know what you
need to remember is that all of this the
debate the excitement over it the I
think bond should be this I think bond
should be that that's part of the joy of
what bond its bond is a myth it's owned
by its audience it's owned by
particularly the UK and the people who
love it here and it's really a homegrown
thing and I think it something to be
celebrated you know and that people have
opinions about it could be take it a
little too seriously sometimes you said
one film so is that it no more for you
well you know I made the mistake last
time I was saying well I wouldn't do it
then I did it so at this time I think
you know takes six months you know and
the worst time really to answer those
questions is two-and-a-half days or
whatever it is since I finished the film
you know suddenly no I mean to think
about another one and and I think it's
unlikely because I think you know I
really feel like this is a you know it's
complete a pair of movies and it's
really I'm really happy I did this one
but it was it was it was really hard
work to begin with you know and and I
think so you know there are other things
that I loved and I'd like to do